[Música]
para agarrar el loro de esa tierra ponen
unas planchas de bronce ya curada porque
para curarle esas planchas tienen que
pasarle bastante oro ella se ven grises
grises cuando usted ve las planchas de
bronce grises le echan azogue y mientras
va corriendo el lado con esa tierra el
loro finito ese es el que va quedando en
la plancha
[Música]
en la comunidad llamado Campo Alegre
había fallecido otro niño ahogado
infectado había muchos casos en esa
misma comunidad porque ya estaban
trabajando con mercurio estaban tomando
esa misma agua que estaba contaminado y
los abuelos ya dos semanas dos muertos
tres muertos y así seguía
[Música]